[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOHIT VIJAYARENU: So I am Lohit.
I work for a company
which builds the platform
to serve public organizations.
It's Twitter.
Or simply put, as
[INAUDIBLE] says,
we send a lot of messages.
So in this talk, we'll describe
Twitter's data replicator
architecture, how we
extended it to Google Cloud
and maintained the same
interface for our users.
Our users are the internal
developers or all the users
within Twitter.
At any point of time, if
you want to ask questions,
you can always tweet to the
hashtag #GoogleNext19Twitter.
A lot of our team
members are here.
They can answer it.
Or I also have time towards
the end of the talk.
So before getting into
the actual replicator,
I want to spend some time
around the data infrastructure
we use for analytics.
So at Twitter, we
primarily use Hadoop
for large scale analytics.
Hadoop Distributed File System,
HDFS, is our primary storage.
We have multiple clusters,
large clusters, which
can host up to exabyte of data.
There are multiple
clusters per use cases.
We have production
clusters, ad hoc clusters.
And each of those clusters have
different properties and also
machine configuration,
based on the use case,
to make sure we always
optimize both the jobs as well
as the cluster utilization.
So this like a diagram of
how the actual data flows
at a very high level.
So whenever users
use twitter.com
or use the Twitter
mobile, their actions
generate a lot of events,
what we call as events.
We generate about 1.5
trillion events every day.
That's about 1 billion
events every minute.
So all these events flow through
a system called a log pipeline.
So each of these events have
a name associated with that.
So the log pipeline is
responsible for aggregating
all the events for the
same name and write them
as log files on HDFS.
We call this as
a real time HDFS.
This acts like a incoming
HDFS and usually does
a lot of cleansing,
format conversion,
and then also does our
time ordered partition,
like [INAUDIBLE]
So all the events
which got generated
from thousands of
different end points
end up as log files for
that particular hour
in the same place.
Right?
We call this real
time Hadoop cluster
is because this is the entry
point for our log files.
The SLA on these
clusters are very high.
This cluster been up for several
years for, as we always do,
a rolling upgrade.
From there, once the
data set gets collected
as a hourly partition, users
would have configured, OK,
which cluster that those
data has to be replicated.
So it can be replicated to
production or ad hoc clusters,
based on the data set
and the configuration.
And then once the data
lands on these clusters,
they run more jobs on that and
generate even more data sets.
And those data sets
can also be configured
to be replicated to either a
cold storage, or production use
cases, and all those things.
Apart from our batch
analytics, the log pipeline
will also stream some of
the events for our real time
computing.
So we use Apache Heron for our
real time computing framework.
So today, overall
in our clusters,
we crunch hundreds
of petabytes of data
everyday across thousands
of jobs turning every day.
So when you look at one of the
cluster, what is in a cluster?
So in a cluster, you
will see many data sets
and the application services
responsible for replicating
that data from somewhere,
from source to this cluster.
With every data
set, there is also
a retention associated with it.
So we have a retention
service which
takes care of deleting the
data based on that data set's
configuration.
We have multiple different
compute frameworks,
like Scalding, Presto, Hive,
like MapReduce jobs, which
crunch the data
and do analytics.
So they interact with
a system called DAL,
or Data Access Layer, which
is like our metadata service.
So the DAL has information
of all the data
sets and the partitions,
hourly partitions,
associated with that data set.
Whenever a replication
service copies a new data set,
the DAL is again updated.
We also have a front
end for the DAL, which
we call the eagle
eye, which gives
a global overview of any
particular data set at Twitter.
So our data set will
have a logical name,
and it will have multiple
physical locations, which
means that same data
set is available
at multiple different clusters.
And we'll also have
different properties
associated with them, like
schema, owner, what kind
of the data it has, like whether
it has PIA data or such, right?
It also has information
about whether this data
set is a hourly partition or
a daily partition and such.
So there are some
more information
in some of the blogs about this.
So I also want to touch upon--
we are like, now
talking about a lot
of data spread across many
different clusters, right?
How do we identify this?
So traditionally, people who
have been using Hadoop know
that, when there was one HDFS,
you used to refer to the data
inside of HDFS using hdfs://,
a name node name, and a port,
and a path within that.
Then came multiple
namespaces and HA.
So with that, the
open source community
introduced the concept
of view file system.
View file system is a
client side mount table
where the client
will resolve which
particular name node it has
to redirect the requests to.
So this way, you could
scale multiple name nodes
and also add in HA
for the name nodes.
So you would reference
something like viewfs://,
and then cluster-X, and
then the data within that.
In this example, we're
following /logs/partly-cloudy.
Partly cloudy is
also the project name
which we use for this effort.
At Twitter, as I said,
we have multiple clusters
and multiple data centers.
So what we ended up doing was
to extend that view file system
to add-- we call it something
called as a Twitter view file
system.
With this, what
you can do is you
can globally identify our data,
which is stored in any cluster.
So you would say /datacenter1,
cluster x, and then the data.
And the client side mount table
will take care of resolving it
to the right Hadoop name node.
So now what happens is that the
tools, such as a replicator,
will use these globally
identifiable parts
and then act upon the data
which it's replicating, right?
So what is the need
for replication?
As I said, we have multiple
different clusters.
This is just a snapshot.
As you can see, we have
thousands of different data
sets people configure.
And they need to be kept
in sync, like not just one
from source to destination, but
there is source, destination,
back.
And then there is
also merging, right?
When you say replication,
at the very high level
we have two kinds
of replication.
One is a source to destination.
It's a one-to-one.
We always make sure
that any new data which
gets generated in
the source has to be
kept in sync with destination.
And we could also have
configuration wherein
you could have multiple
sources, and all the data
belonging to that
particular add has
to be merged and made
available at the destination.
So this is like a
copy plus merge.
So when users set
up a replication,
so typically what
they do is they
provide a data set name,
like a partly-cloudy
as a data set name.
They provide source
cluster and source path,
destination cluster and
the destination path,
and some other properties
associated with that,
and then add it to a
metadata layer, such as DAL.
Replicator would fetch
that entry from DAL
and basically translate it
to saying that, OK, data
set partly-cloudy-- and this is
my source globally identified
path and globally
identified destination.
So what is replicator
actually doing?
So a replicator is like a
[INAUDIBLE] running daemon,
which we run it on
frameworks such as Mesos
so that, even if
the node goes down,
Mesos can actually,
automatically start
that replicator somewhere else.
It's completely stateless.
Whenever it stacks up,
it queries DAL and then
asks, so give me all
the configurations
which is responsible for a
particular destination cluster.
So we run one replicator
per destination cluster.
So it is responsible
in making sure
that all the data sets
from different sources
are in sync at the
destination cluster.
So after fetching those
entries, for each of this entry,
it will do a metadata lookup
from the source cluster
to destination cluster.
Basically, it does
a directory listing
to make sure all the
partitions are in sync.
If any new partitions
are available,
then it kicks off a MapReduce
job, called Hadoop Distcp job.
And Distcp job is the
one which is actually
transferring the data.
The red arrow shows
And then Distcp
job writes locally
at the destination cluster.
As you can see, the source path
is ClusterX/logs/partly-cloudy.
And then there is [INAUDIBLE].
And the destination
would be transferred
to the globally
identified path here.
In cases where we have to
merge multiple data sets--
this is for data sets, as I
said, in the very beginning.
The incoming data lands
on [? RT ?] clusters.
So we have that set up on
multiple different data
centers.
So for a developer who
needs to access data
for a particular hour
across all our data centers,
we need to make sure that we
merge for that particular hour.
So in this case, what
happens is the replicator
identifies that this data set
is of type multiple sources.
So it will kick off one
Distcp job per source
to destination, independent.
And once it is done, it
will merge all of them
into a temporary space, and
then does a final atomic rename.
So once after this is
done, it will make a call
to DAL saying that this
particular data set
at the destination cluster
for that particular hour
is now available.
So all the tools who have
been waiting on the new data
can automatically start
consuming the data.
So when we decided to
migrate some of our workload
to GCP to unlock
new features on GCP,
we started looking what all data
needs to be replicated in GCP.
And just like the
previous configuration,
this was even more complicated.
The data was spread across
multiple different clusters,
and we had to replicate
all of them to GCP.
And once it lands on GCP, we
could unlock a lot of tools,
such as Presto on GCP,
Scalding, Hadoop clusters
on GCP, BigQuery.
All the data which gets
replicated with GCS
can be loaded into
BigQuery, and then unlock
all these different
possibilities.
So what did we do?
We tried to see
how did we do this.
So remember, I talked about the
View FileSystem, Twitter View
FileSystem.
So to access the data which
is stored in Google GCS,
which is a bucket in GCS,
you use something like this,
gs:// and then bucket
name, logs.partly-cloudy.
So Google has open-sourced
this library called,
Cloud Storage Connector.
What it essentially is--
Hadoop file system API is
like an abstract file system.
And all the other file systems
can implement those interfaces.
Like HDFS is actually
an implementation
of that file system.
So Google has implemented
the same interface
to provide the file
system abstraction
for the additional upper layers.
So anybody who is using
the file system APIs
can transparently access
Google Cloud Storage
as if they're using
some Hadoop command.
So all the Hadoop commands,
the jobs which you run,
everything will run as is.
So we plugged this one
to our View FileSystem
as a mount point.
So what we did was any path in
Twitter which refers to /gcs
will automatically
translate to buckets on GCS,
using the Google Cloud
Storage Connector.
Right?
So let's look at what is
happening with the replicator.
So for the most
part, we didn't have
to change too much
in replicator code
because it was using the
Hadoop file system APIs.
But what we ended up doing was,
as of our other applicators,
we run a GCS replicator
per destination.
We created something called
as a Copy Cluster, which
acts as a destination, and set
up a replicator for GCS alone.
So this Copy Cluster has
all the GCS mount points,
as I described.
So any data which gets returned
to /gcs is transparently
getting redirected to Google
Cloud Storage buckets.
So when you're replicating an
input data set from a ClusterX
to a destination /gcs, what is
happening is the Distcp job is
transferring the data
from the source cluster.
And using the Cloud
Storage Connector,
it's writing the data
directly to buckets on GCS.
So for this to
happen, we had to do
a few things for the network.
So as I said, the
replicator does two things.
One is the metadata
operation, which
is it compares the source
directories and the destination
directories.
So for that, we used a proxy
to reach the Google endpoints,
because the amount
of data which gets
transferred around metadata
operations is not that much.
But the actual data is in
the order of petabytes.
So what our network
engineering team did
was to create this Twitter and
Google PNI, Private Network
Interconnect, so that all
the worker nodes in our Copy
Cluster have direct access
to the Google endpoints.
So now, any jobs which
are running any task
Distcp jobs which are running
on Copy Cluster, whenever
it has to write some
data, it can directly
write to GCS for us.
Apart from that, Google
also has this concept
of multiregion bucket.
And while we were
doing this testing,
they introduced
dual-region buckets
wherein any data you
write into those buckets
are only available
in two regions.
And from either of the
two regions, if you write,
it will be automatically
available to access
from the other region.
So our network engineering team
also created that PNI setup
for the data centers.
We have multiple
different data centers.
Whichever was closer
to the region,
they created that interface.
So now for cases
of [INAUDIBLE] copy
where we have multiple sources
writing into a destination,
we can set up Distcp
jobs independently.
And all of them can
write into the same path
at the destination.
So we also did this
because renames on HDFS
is pretty cheap, because
you have a name node.
But on an object store,
it was pretty expensive.
So for this particular
Distcp jobs alone,
it understands that
they are writing to GCS.
So they try to write
in place, right?
So now, how do you get any
consistency in this case?
So in such cases,
what we did was--
this shows a state
diagram of how
two replicators with multiple
different sources writing
to a single destination
achieves consistency.
So each of the
replicator basically
kicks off it's part of the copy.
And all the files have a data
center name embedded in them.
So there is no name
conflict, to begin with.
So once the copy is done, each
of the replicator will create
an _SUCCESS and source
data center name in there.
So once it is done, each of them
independently will check if all
_SUCCESS have been found.
If they are found, they'll
make a call to DAL to say,
hey, the data set for the merge
data set is available on GCS.
Even if there are multiple
updates to DAL, it is OK.
So these are [INAUDIBLE]
important operations.
So we are OK in such cases.
So with all this setup, how
does it look for our users?
One of the goal is to
make sure that we have
a uniform access for our users.
So EagleEye, as I said,
is a front-end interface
for our DAL.
Whenever we are
replicating to GCS,
we are also publishing
those partitions in DAL.
So this EagleEye, if you
see for a particular data
set logs particularly, there are
multiple different locations,
physical locations,
dw2_hdfs, hive, and all.
And now, GCS becomes just
another destination for them.
So for them, the data is
in HDFS, as well as GCS.
And you also have a
graph, which shows
the latency of copying each
partition to GCS, just like how
we have for our HDFS clusters.
So DAL provides a lot of APIs to
identify for a particular data
set what are all the partition.
It also has command-line tools.
Now if you were to query,
OK, show me a logical data
set named called partly-cloudy,
you get an entry.
And when you actually look
at all the physical locations
for that, you can see there is
one is HDFS, and one is GCS.
So it's the same interface,
same APIs for our users
who have been using DAL.
And you can query
all the partitions
for that particular data set
at a particular location.
So it will give you
hourly partitions.
As and when replicator
is copying data,
it is also publishing
this information
to DAL, the uniform
interface for our users.
Not just users, like for
ourselves or our SREs.
So since it's just another
instance of replicator,
we use the same
monitoring tools.
So in this case, we are showing
for a particular category what
is the read/write bytes and what
is the latency of replicating
from source to destination.
So one of those colors is
basically just another cloud
replicator for us.
We have also comprehensive
alerting for our existing
replicator.
The same thing translated for
the Google replicator, as well.
We have one.
And if there is some
problems, for example,
in the bottom graph, you see
some Distcp jobs are failing.
So we can configure rules
which will say pages
if you cross some threshold.
So as part of organizing all
the resources in GCP, tomorrow
morning, there is an excellent
talk from our teammate,
[INAUDIBLE],, who's going to
talk more about how we organize
our projects, and resources,
and users into different GCP
projects.
So you should
definitely check it out.
So essentially, on GCP,
we have different projects
for different organization.
Now, we took advantage of
that and said, OK, we'll
deploy different
replicators per project.
And these replicators
are going to be
using separate service
account credentials and all
those things.
So all the data which is owned
by a particular organization,
that replicator will be
responsible for replicating
the data.
So if you have
problems with the keys,
you just have to rotate the keys
for that particular replicator.
Or if you want to do
some updates, or testing,
or anything, so just
adding another more
replicator for that.
We also did one more thing.
As I said, in the
Twitter View FileSystem,
it's basically a client-side
mount table to say,
if you have two namespaces,
you would have two entries,
saying that anything which
starts with the prefix,
go to first entry.
If not, second.
But with GCS, what
happens is we'll
be managing thousands of
users, which translates
to thousands of buckets.
And also, you will have
hundreds of categories or data
sets, which translates to
hundreds of different buckets.
So instead of creating hundreds
of entries in the client-side
mount table, what we ended up
doing is to implement a regular
expression-based client-side
mount table wherein the path,
such as /gcs/logs/partly-cloudy,
will translate
to gs:logx.partly-cloudy.
We also are maintaining a
well-defined naming convention
for our bucket.
So this makes it very
easy for us to do
this regex-based conversion.
So with all this setup,
where are we today?
We have tens of
different of instances
of these replicators
per project, per test
setup across multiple data
centers, which are running.
We have copied petabytes,
tens of petabytes of data.
Many use cases have been
unlocked, like BigQuery,
Presto, and GCP, and all.
And there will be lot of
blog posts coming soon
about all those things.
And so this effort was made
possible only with close
collaboration with
the folks at Google.
So while we were testing
this out and then doing
some iterations,
there were a lot
of enhancements for the
Google Cloud Hadoop connector.
For example, when
we started off,
HDFS has a different
checksum than GCS.
So if you run a Distcp
job, even though the data
is copied successfully,
it will check the checksum
and say, there is corruption.
And then it will
rerun the job again.
It will delete everything
and then rerun the job again.
So when we talked with
the Google engineers,
they identified this.
And then they started to make
changes to the Hadoop code
itself to provide a flexible
checksum option, which
is now open-source.
There's also a blog
post about that.
And while that was
happening, we also
made modifications
to our Distcp jobs
to do a streaming checksum
until this was deployed.
There were various
other enhancements
of other replicators, such
as proxy configuration
as a path to a file, instead of
encoding user name and password
of a proxy credential.
Because what used to
happen is that used
to get loaded into
configuration object.
And in Hadoopland, once it
is in configuration object,
it gets passed
around everywhere.
And also when we
started off, Google
had only one way to specify
one user credentials.
And then with that, we changed
it to per user credential.
Whoever is running
the command, we
can dynamically pick up their
credentials to access GCS.
And when we were integrating
with our View FileSystem,
lazy initialization support
for the Google Cloud Storage.
Apart from that,
we have other teams
who are also evaluating a lot
of stuff on GCS, for example,
Presto.
So they discovered a lot of
performance improvements,
so which translated into
changes both at our end,
open-source Presto
community, and also GCS.
So this was a very
good collaboration.
There'll be some blog posts.
And a lot of things around the
Google Cloud Storage Connector,
especially for the
object store, because we
have been used to using HDFS.
And our applications
are used to thinking
in HDFS kind of way, wherein
renames, for example,
are atomic.
But that is not possible on GCS.
So Google folks implemented this
cooperative locking wherein,
if you turn on that flag,
if multiple people are
trying to do a rename,
then it will take a log
and do a rename.
And then there is the FSCK for
recovery and all those things.
And in most of
the cases, what we
do is, whenever these
stuff are open-source,
we try to use the same
version, as much as possible.
That also makes it very easy for
us to report any support cases.
Whenever we file a
support case with Google,
we can just say the
version which we are using.
And they can refer to
the open-source version
and say, OK, this is
what was happening.
They can refer the code.
So that makes it very easy.
In summary, I hope I was able
to explain the replicator
architecture, while extending
it to the Google Cloud
and maintaining the same
consistent interface
for our users.
I also want to acknowledge
a few of our team members.
A lot of people worked on many
different components of this.
And this special link,
cloud.google.com.twitter,
where there'll be a lot
more information, and blog
posts, and linking,
cross-linking and such.
Finally, we have a lot of
openings across the board.
And I encourage you to
tweet or apply online.
[MUSIC PLAYING]